Này 2 mẹ tăng tăng sáng, chỉ quyền về một dung sáng tình quy châu chú cốp,
bán mũ cạnh báo khẩn cấp các một mức cảm nhất.
Nhà mính khó đợi lụi nếu chảo vệ lấn kia xa đơn ngày 2 mít tự tháng sáng.
Sở báo chú thấy mực nơi sông đồ liệu sẽ đặt lình 2 chăm năm ba phẩy năm ấy,
bước xanh ở ăn toàn.
Lực lượng cứ hộ nếu sớt tảnh hạnh chục in người ra khỏi khu đực huyền.
Các bộ thủy lợi chú cốp, mười ba có xong lấn tại các tình miền Nam,
như bất năng quy châu khoảng tay và hải năng đều vượt mức tạnh báo.
Mới lớn trong bán ngày qua một số địa sương,
cào gấp đôi mức trường mình đứng sấu.
Tại thấy là, thủ tương vi thông tháng xin ở tràn đã chực tiếp tỉ sát tình chương rài,
nơi hơn 3 miền bày trong mua nhà và tảm mời tả đất đường nghiệp biển gặp.
Phôn đổi hong ra đấu vi động thương kiện chuyên dục để xấu tả người dân cho ký chính quyền tạnh báo khả năng
sảy ra lụi quay trong người lớn tí tục.
Chúng tôi cạnh biển lộ tí hậu ngày càng tăng đồng mạnh
và khu ra đồng là má đặc trực kế tư hiện tượng thử tiếp tục răng,
sẽ ra với tẩn xuân dài hơn và bức độ nghiêm trọng hơn.